Howard Bek joins us on loan from
Bleacher Report's senior NBA writer his
most recent column Bryant to Shaq two
decades after one of the wildest turning
points in NBA history Lakers blazers
royalty recall the LOB that tied Kobe
and Shaq together forever sparked a
three-peat and up ended a powerhouse
good morning Howard when did you decide
to do Bryant to Shaq good morning Dan
and let me just humbly say that without
saying it publicly I think this is one
of the greatest oral histories well done
I so you know I obviously I covered that
series for the LA Daily News back in the
day and it was just always one of my
favorite games one of my favorite
moments that lob and one of my favorite
series and it's also just this wonderful
sliding doors moment because of course
they were down 15 in the fourth quarter
of that game and probably arguably
should have lost and if they had there
is no dynasty and the Blazers probably
win the championship and history is much
different and I've wanted to return to
this for a long time I almost did it
four years ago in fact your upcoming
guest Bob Costas and I spoke four years
ago when I first started poking around
to do something on this it got shelved
at the time we revived it more recently
unfortunately for two reasons the 20th
anniversary of that game and also of
course the passing of Kobe in January
favorite interview with this was who
well I got five players from each team
Plus Mike Dunleavy senior Phil Jackson I
emailed a little bit but that was it so
I got a lot of great voices I think out
of all of them you know bonzi was really
great bonds he was a lot of fun bonds
Ewell's was one of these guys who back
in the day I think had kind of you know
that this this jaded view of him this
the reputation because of those Blazers
teams at the time that he was looked at
as kind of a young knucklehead and you
know part of that crew that was often
derided as the GL Blazers which I think
is a terrible unfortunate term that's
that still unfortunately lives um
bonds II was wonderful he he just he he
could tell you all of the pain and
anguish of being part of that collapse
but in a way that that history and time
has given him the perspective of it he
was candid he was fun to talk to he told
me this great thing that did not
the piece which I just want throwing
real quick he said that before Game
seven which one is on a Sunday that
night a Saturday night he says I went to
bed at 10 o'clock I went to bed at 10
o'clock on a Saturday night in LA
because I knew I had to deal with Kobe
and I knew that Kobe Bryant wasn't gonna
be out partying on a Saturday night and
so the only person on earth who could
make me go to bed at 10 o'clock on a
Saturday night in LA
it was Kobe yeah you look back on that
era and I I remember saying it when they
broke up that will remember what they
didn't accomplish and not necessarily
what they did accomplish do you know
what the real core the reason was that
Shaq and Kobe broke up it was Laird Dan
I mean the easy reductive version is
well
Kobe didn't want him there anymore and
Kobe had all the leverage in the world
because he was entering free agency and
if Shaq had stayed Kobe could have
walked across the hallway to the
Clippers which he had flirted with doing
all season and in fact had sent very
strong signals including to Mike
Dunleavy you know who was at that time
the coach of the Clippers and and I
think GM as well so there was there was
that and and that's not to be diminished
but there were other factors Shaq wanted
a max extension which at that time
remember Shaq's salary had been
grandfathered in before there were maxes
in the NBA there was no max salary when
he got his big deal to join the Lakers
in the first place so they were
constantly building on this huge salary
that was bigger than anybody else's and
he was getting up there in just you know
years and mileage he of course it had
some serious injuries or at least
nagging injuries so Jerry Buss didn't
want to give him the extension to the
extent that Shaq wanted it so Shaq had
been pouting all year about that and so
that was a big part of it to Dan
but yeah listen at the core of it you
could see it in the 2004 Finals against
Detroit Kobe and Shaq wanted nothing to
do with each other by that point they
had already they hadn't been split up
technically but they were already done
talking to Howard Beck Bleacher Report's
senior NBA writer the column and it's a
it's a deep dive it's great there's so
much detail here and talking to the
principals involved in this Bryant to
Shaq it's on a bleacher report I was
talking about Wilt Chamberlain's place
in history and it feels like we don't
embrace him the way we do Babe Ruth
there's certain guys that we pick and
choose of what we point out or
what we leave out you know Bill Russell
was a flawed offensive player shot 44
percent from the floor wasn't a good
free-throw shooter but he won 11 titles
you know Kobe won five but he can't be
Michael so you know how high do you put
him up like it's weird how we pick and
choose Tim Duncan he's the greatest
power forward of all time he's a center
but he wanted to be a power for I just
don't know in 10 or 15 years from now
who is in the top ten now that won't be
in the top ten greatest players of all
time who's gonna fall out and who's
going in in your opinion oh boy I guess
it depends on who's in your top ten
right now it's it's you know and by the
way like for me every time I'm ever
asked this I always punch and it's not
because I'm trying to be cowardly or
screaming it's just comparing players
and teams across the eras in the NBA
maybe more than any other sport is just
impossible the game has evolved so much
has changed in so many dramatic ways the
style of play the pace of play you know
even though even that you know obviously
the the the width of the key like
everything changes and so it's hard to
make these comparisons dan and you know
you were alluding to it earlier before I
came on about the the narratives or the
the tag lines that we affixed to each of
these guys and I think they're
appropriate because it's it's our
shorthand way of encapsulating what they
meant
right what Bill Russell meant was he was
the ultimate champion we don't get into
the stats and the nitty-gritty and we
don't have as much data for that era
anyway it stands on its own
he was the greatest champion of all time
we'll the most dominant of all time and
it doesn't matter how many championships
he won you know Michael Jordan is just
simply the goat and LeBron is trying to
challenge him for that and some people
think it's a one-two race and others say
no you're forgetting Kareem who was the
real greatest of all time you know it
you can go round and round on this I
mean Kevin Durant you asked who's gonna
break in Kevin Durant's not already in I
think he should be yeah I left two
amount so you got staff who's gonna be
in Durant is gonna be in and I guess I
got to make way for the Greek freak to
maybe be a top-10 player of all time see
if he most idols
if yes y'all stop short on that one only
because
he's still so early in his career you
can see the outline of one of the
all-time greats and skill set wise an
impact on the game over the last couple
of years you can already say that that's
that he's there but longevity matters
too right you're the imprint you make
needs to last at least kind of a half
decade to a decade so let's let's wait
until we've seen the longevity and how
far he can take it all but yeah just the
sheer dominance on the court you could
put his skill set his total package of
skills up against anybody how do you
think history treats James Harden that's
a that's a really really interesting one
and this is a big you know as weird as
this postseason is going to be in the
Orlando bubble it's a really important
one for him because he's gonna turn 31 I
think this summer maybe during the
bubble and you know he's got all the
accolades all the individual
accomplishments he is one of the
greatest scorers of all time but you
know this is when we start really you
know picking somebody apart well he was
one of the greatest scorers we've ever
seen but the aesthetics of his game
weren't that appealing to a lot of
people he was one of the greatest
scorers of all time but he never made
the finals he never won a ring and so
he's got that you know hanging over him
right now and if if he never wins the
big one look there's a plenty that we
have a large list of guys long list of
guys you know the charles barkley and
karl malone and john stockton who you
know Patrick Ewing guys who we know are
all-time greats who never won the big
one it happens there is some elements of
luck and timing and supporting cast and
all these other things but Harden has
the added difficulty in this discussion
of his own performance is what has often
held his teams back in the postseason so
he does have that burden but do you
think does history look favourably more
so on Russell Westbrook or James Harden
I think history that will look better on
James Harden than Russell Westbrook and
and look you know my bias in this
discussion is that of the two of them
I've always thought James Harden was the
better overall offensive weapon let's
face it neither one of them is going to
be ever be known for their defense
they're both great playmakers in
different ways and Westbrook had the
gaudier stance if you want to count just
the triple doubles which I think have
become a little
exaggerated in terms of importance as
impressive as it is Hardin is far far
far more efficient he is miles better
from three-point range and just overall
more efficient whether you're using true
shooting percentage or effective field
goal percentage or any other measure
Hardin is the more efficient player let
me go back to your column before I touch
on the NBA's plan to return where do you
rank Shaq and Kobe of greatest duo's in
NBA history it's tough I mean I don't I
don't want to use my backdoor out here
as I did earlier because I already
pulled that card give me your best duo's
of all time you don't have to crank oh
all right look the one that leaps to
mind immediately is Michael and Scottie
they were just the versatility the
two-way impact of the two of them
offensively and defensively they were
just phenomenal those teams were
beautiful to watch it was great that we
got the last dance recently because
whether you were you know in our age
range and had lived through it watched
it as fans and just got the refresher or
if you were younger fans who never saw
them they just played an incredible
brand of basketball obviously magic and
Kareem are right up there Shaq and Kobe
are in the discussion there's no
question and Shaq the way Shaq always
puts and I think did again in my story
is that they're the best
you know big man guard combo of all time
would you put them over Kareem in magic
as I wouldn't it it's it's tough Kareem
has more overall accomplishments than
Shaq you might link Kobe over magic
although Magic's playmaking and maybe
the greatest point guard of all time you
know generally speaking you know
generally considered that it it's it's
tough I don't know I I think if you
asked Laker fans that it would be
completely breaking along generational
lines probably so we have an idea a
loser's tournament the eight teams that
don't get invited to Orlando why not
allow them to be you know you have a
warm-up band when you go see you know
the Rolling Stones so you have a warm-up
act where you have the eight teams
playing and they played over three games
and then the winner of the tournament
gets the number one pick in the draft
single elimination number one pick in
the draft and it's a loose
tournament we eliminate tanking here for
good Howard so this is not just for 2020
this is in perpetuity well let's start
this year and then see how it works you
know I think I love the idea and I love
anything that incentivizes the worst
teams to actually try here comes the
budding it come on give me the bunt here
but not this year
because the whole point of the exercise
in Orlando is safety and so the reason
we're going 22 and not 30 and frankly I
think it should have been 16 is that
more bodies more teams equals more risk
more tests more everything so if you'd
now take the other eight and put them in
their own bubble somewhere and have the
losers tournament you've got to deal
with all the coronavirus concerns all
over again
there's my buzzkill I'm sorry the team
to beat when this tournament starts is
the Lakers they have LeBron they were
the the team with the most momentum
going into the suspension of the season
they had just beaten the Bucks and
Clippers over that that prior weekend
and you know I I picked the Clippers
back in October Dan and I still feel
like top to bottom the Clippers have the
overall better depths collection of
talent and they've gotten elements in
Lou Williams that the Lakers just don't
have they both have a top two but the
liquid the Clippers have a third guy who
can drop 25 in a given night the Lakers
just don't and so I still lean that way
intellectually but the Lakers had the
momentum now does momentum get you from
March 11th through this massive gap for
July 31st
probably not but they they deserve the
benefit of the doubt your wildcard team
to win it all ooh I don't think there's
a wild card in the West it's either the
Lakers of the Clippers the Rockets you
don't think see I looked at the Rockets
and said if they happen to capture magic
in a bottle here with their small ball
then I then they're the team that I
would be the and they I would look at
them as the outlier here in the West
they're fun for that reason because
they've just got the firepower is
amazing and yes maybe if things break
their way couple calls plus there's no
home court advantage and we don't know
what anybody's going to look like when
they come back or what kind of chemistry
or rhythm and
buddy is in I still think they rely too
much on individual talent James Harden's
gonna score this time Russell West was
gonna score this time there's no real
collaborative effort there and that's
what breaks down in the playoffs if you
were a superb individual talent but the
rest of the cast is not involved there's
so much isolation play I think that's
where it breaks down for the Rockets um
I think the sleepers were in the East um
if the Bucks are going in as everybody's
you know kind of agreed-upon favorite
and they should be Toronto's really
strong
even without Kawhi they were they've had
a phenomenal season
I love the Celtics young talent and the
way they were coming together I don't I
wouldn't put it out of the the
possibility that pik-wan Howard you get
one come on okay
it's Toronto then okay they're defending
champs so that's it feels cheap but
they're the defending champs without the
MVP of the finals yeah I liked Boston
I guess Philadelphia are they an outlier
here
I think Philly is is in the East what
the Rockets are in the West like a lot
of question marks but the talent is
there
and now that they've had all this time
for Simmons and embiid to get healthy
there's a shot he's Howard back Bleacher
Report's senior NBA writer and it's a
great read you don't have to be a Laker
fan if you're a blazer fan you're not
going to enjoy this but it's a call
Bryant to Shaq and it's on bleach report
Howard great to talk to you again are
you going to Orlando still weighing that
right now I'm not gonna go in for the
bubble because that requires that long
lockdown and way too much time away and
very little payoff in terms of access
I'm Dwayne whether to go just for the
finals but that would probably be it
unfortunately good to talk to you Thank
You Howard appreciate you Dan thank you